you and i have a similar had a similar
experience that i wanted to bring up
which is both of us
uh hosted uh the white house
correspondents dinner
during the uh o'brien i'm done deal
brian
that's an amazing freudian slip
during the o'brien the o'bryant
administration
yes you will announce something conan i
i just want to say that i feel in many
ways i co-ran the country with barack
obama during that eight year period
no during the obama administration we
both
had a chance to do the white house
correspondents dinner uh that's a
thrilling gig
i found it to be very exciting i had
done it once under clinton and then
uh with with the with the obamas there
what people don't know and i think you
had this experience too
is that uh the comedian goes after the
president
so we're sitting there and president
obama would get up
absolutely destroy great jokes amazing
delivery
and i was sitting next to you you sit
next to the first lady so you sit next
to michelle obama
while you're watching the president kill
and then you know you have to go up next
what was that experience like for you uh
you pretty much mapped it out yeah i
mean it's
you're sitting there and you you have
your you know i can't i have my cards
and he's just killing and he's doing
some
stuff that i was gonna do so yes that's
what
that's what i wanted to talk about yeah
yeah yeah so i'm you
so you really have to listen to make
sure you don't you know do a joke he's
doing
right and um and while he's doing why
he's going through you know doing his
act the first lady is just like
trying to talk to me trying to make you
know
make some some some contact here
and and i know she was just being nice
being very generous and trying to make
me feel comfortable
and maybe trying to relax me but that's
not what you do to a comedian
when we gotta go up who's about to go on
yeah
no i know exactly what you're talking
about because i was sitting there
and i'm i'm watching uh the president
like a hawk
because he's doing he's covering all
these all these areas
and of course i've got my like 50 cards
of all the jokes i'm going to do
and i'm flipping through and then he'll
mention something he'll he'll he'll
mention an area and i'll go like ah
and i'll find that card and rip it up
and meanwhile yes
yes mrs yes mrs first lady yes mrs obama
yes the
i i do like pudding i'm going to have my
pudding hold on a second what's that
and it's just it's crazy making it's
crazy making
but it was still you know uh she was
absolutely delightful
and incredibly nice
and then um one of the first things the
president did when i was
uh sitting there when he got up was he
made some kind of just fun harmless dig
at me like it was a roast and he just
did a
a dig at me and the whole crowd was
wondering well what do we think about
this
and the first lady shook her head like
no and gave me a put her arms around me
like not
conan and the whole crowd was like
[Laughter]
so i oh i owe the first lady a huge one
uh for that